it looks just like any other midsize
airport
but the felipe angeles ero puerto built
to serve mexico city was a serious point
of contention long before it opened on
monday
mostly because president andres manuel
lopez obrador cancelled this 13 billion
dollar mega airport a third of the way
through construction to build felipe
angeles instead he said that project
undertaken by the previous
administration was riddled with
corruption
[Music]
now he's built his own he arrived on
monday feeling vindicated
adversaries i laugh
because when i said that on the 21st of
march the airport would be ready our
adversity said it wouldn't be possible
lopez obrador's airport is cheaper than
the scrap one but it's also smaller
it'll only work in combination with the
other already overcrowded old one and
it's far from the capital it serves
have a look at the distances from our
office in the center here's the existing
airport then the one the president
scrapped then his new one
and worse the transport links to get
there aren't finished
you can see that the motorway that
should mean that people can get to the
airport a bit quicker is still under
construction there's also going to be a
light train to ferry passengers there
but that isn't finished yet either and
apparently will be at some point next
year so this is still very much a
project that's under construction
meanwhile that means travel times of
more than two hours from the center in
traffic
some are also worried about who built
and who will partly run the airport the
army they're involved in almost all this
government's mega projects and have a
lot of influence
but the president's many fans there to
watch the launch were just as exuberant
as he was
it's a first-class airport i know a lot
of them and this is at the same level as
the shanghai airport
many might differ but at least it's up
and running now the jury's out and if it
will just be an unloved second option to
the main older airport where a felipe
angeles will really take off john holman
al jazeera mexico city